I've been saying for a number of years,
that all roads lead to narcissism and for the people I know
who vote that way, they voted that way.
And then when it kind of will themselves to be correct,
because it's his ostensibly, what you're saying is,
is you're a Democrat. Yes. You vote Democrat. Yes.
Then you're responsible for Gavin Newsome and Garcetti.
Yes. Well then you're wrong. The next thing you can say is you're wrong.
You're wrong. And these are people that hate being wrong.
They have huge egos and they never want to be wrong.
So it's like a kind of a cognitive dissonance. It's kind of like, yeah,
I voted for that guy and yeah, he's doing a horrible job,
but I'm going to vote for that party again,
because that way I'll never have to admit I was wrong,
but you are wrong because they're running the state into the ocean.
[Inaudible].
And that many public people in Cali that are really publicly fighting the
lockdowns and trying to get people back to work, your whole,
your whole sort of public existence is,
is sort of based around the value of work and your story about work.
And you like it. You like people that work, basically you see value in work.
What do you, what's your take on just the nobody's working? I mean,
we got companies with people working thankfully,
but a lot of people aren't working.
You know, I think the, the problem it's, it's, it's kind of a,
it's a leftist Democrat sort of mindset,
which is why do you work? And the answer is to get money,
to buy food, to take care of your family, to pay rent. Okay, well,
what if we just paid your rent and gave you food? And it's like, well,
that would seem to handle the problem mathematically at first glance.
But you're forgetting about a super important part of work,
which is self worth and pride and self-esteem,
and the depression that kicks in and all that, once you get on the Dole.
So their thing is they have this bizarre approach to reverse
engineer. Everything like, Hey, if, if,
if a lot of young black teens are being suspended from schools,
then stop suspending young, black deets. It's like, okay,
that's not going to fix anything. If, if, if homelessness is illegal,
then don't make it illegal anymore. Like this gas in. And it's that way too.
It's like the prisons are overcrowded. How do we fix that?
Let everyone out of prison. Well, that obviously doesn't fix, you know,
the 75% of the kids can't do math at grade level.
Well then lower the test course. It's like, okay,
your car's not going fast enough.
Well then bust the glass of the speedometer and take your finger and turn the
needle up to 80 miles an hour. You're still going 23 miles. Why is it though?
I think I've asked you this publicly on the show last time.
And I know we've talked about it privately. Why is it though?
That so many people cannot make the jump from
the stupid decisions to their involvement in the stupid decisions that no matter
how many times they voted people in policies that make everything worse.
Like right now,
if you and I walked out of our studios and we just started talking to people on
the street and use that to be like, how's it going in LA? Everybody would say,
man, it's a freaking mess. Or if you said how's Gavin Newsome do.
And they'd all say horrible. Nope. There's nobody defending these people at the,
you know, I get there's the rabid sorta crazies, but pretty much nobody else.
But why is it? And is it, is it just because of the weather?
It has fried all of our brains, basically. It's nice out.
So people cannot realize that the, the stupid, easy answers,
aren't the actual answers.
I've been saying for a number of years, that all roads lead to narcissism.
And for the people I know who vote that way,
they voted that way. And then what to kind of will themselves to be correct.
Because his ostensibly, what you're saying is,
is you're Democrat. Yes. You vote Democrat. Yes.
Then you're responsible for Gavin Newsome and Garcetti.
Yes. Well then you're wrong. The next thing you can say is you're wrong.
You're wrong. And these are people that hate being wrong.
They have huge egos and they never want to be wrong.
So it's like a kind of a cognitive dissonance. It's kind of like, yeah,
I voted for that guy and yeah, he's doing a horrible job,
but I'm going to vote for that party again,
because that way I'll never have to admit I was wrong,
but you are wrong because the running the state into the ocean.
It has no money. There's homeless people, everywhere. Drug addicts are.
Education's horrible. Do you think maybe we should try voting for somebody else?
Did, did you see when, uh, uh, who was it? Um,
bill Maher had Adam chiffon and Mars complaining. Mara's going, Oh,
all of my friends are leaving LA because of high taxes and blah, blah, blah.
And shifts like, Oh, well, we're the business friendly party.
And it's meaningless what he's saying, of course.
But I want it to kind of smack bill Maher through the TV and be like,
what are you talking about?
You are the one that's supporting all of these people.
And then all your friends leave. And you wonder why you're alone.
Well, sometimes they don't even say, we're the party of, they just go, well,
people are leaving because of over-regulation and high taxes and a bad
business environments. Like, yes,
they're leaving because of all the policies you enacted,
those are your policies. That's why they're leaving. Yeah.
They, they seem to be unable to make that, that jump lockdowns.
I know you're not happy. You're as as I am.
You're you're tweeting about it all the time. Do you think there's any,
like on the science level,
do you just think there's any science behind any of this? At this point,
there are a lot. I mean, again, right now we could both walk out.
We live about 20 minutes away from each other,
but we can walk outside of our house. It's a beautiful day, as it always is.
We cannot sit outside and have a, because of lockdowns.
Yeah. At a place where you purchase a coffee. I think you could,
we could probably go up to your roof deck.
Actually. I, well, you are welcome on my roof deck, but according to Garcetti,
you're not supposed to be on my right.
Oh, right. Well, a lot of it is, you know,
most of it is the crops are dying.
We need a Virgin to throw in the volcano and someone goes,
how's that going to help the crops? And they go, you shut up.
I got to do something. The villagers are upset. They want action.
I mean, whoever the, the, uh, health minister or,
or czar or whatever of Los Angeles is much as admitted it, like I said,
outdoor dining, isn't dangerous. We don't have any data to support.
It's dangerous, but we want people to stay home.
But you're not making that up. That is what the guy said. Yeah. Okay.
Well, first things first, do you get to decide who stays home?
That's your job?
Your job is I will decide when you get to leave your house.
And even if it's for spurious reasons,
and there is no direct correlation between any danger of spreading the disease
and eating outdoors,
I'm still just going to make this random decision and you shall stay home.
I mean, it's a very, it's funny. It's a,
it's a comment that kind of slid by a lot of people, but it's,
it's a very scary precedent when the powers that be are
essentially saying you're going to stay home because I told you to stay home and
then you go, give me proof why I should stay home. And they go,
I don't have to give you proof. I told you to stay home.
Are you shocked? How quickly we all became sheep? I mean, everybody, everybody.
Well, what, what, what I've realized, what,
what has happened is California, especially Los Angeles,
especially it's. So over-regulated,
it's so burdensome it's so it's so
tyrannical and its,
its leaders are so tyrannical in terms of its burden that they put on the
taxpayers that we all got sort of indoctrinated into this slowly.
Like Magine trying to pull this off in 1955. Right?
People viscerally like, uh, no, I'm not staying home. And by the way, I'm I'm,
by the way, when I leave my house, I'm taking my gun in case one of you,
try to try to arrest me. Like that's where we would be at. But it was a slow,
quiet indoctrination of, I mean, think about what you can't do.
Here's what you can't do. Here's what you must do. Here's all the things,
you know, you, you can't smoke in a restaurant. Okay.
Well go to the smoking and no smoking. Oh, then I'll go to the bar. No,
no smoking at the bar. Well then I'll go to the patio, no smoking a bad,
like it's such a crazy, um,
Stockholm syndrome that everyone lives.
Everyone that in California has a kind of a Stockholm syndrome.
Like I would S I say all the time, Hey, your business, your restaurant.
There's no reason why you need to shut down your outdoor dining.
You've made a lot of concessions. You spent a lot of money just eff.
These guys stay open. And I was like, ah, I don't want to get into trouble.
Well, that's what the overregulation has created. This, this,
this huge sort of umbrella, always, you know,
under the guise of safety and everyone is just scared, but,
but slowly scared, like, just think about,
think about, you know, what? Think about the beach.
I always talk about the beach, but think about the beach.
Like imagine telling someone from the fifties and Malibu, Hey,
you can't have that cigarette on the beach. Ooh. What are you doing?
I'm drinking a beer. You can't drink a beer on the beach. I mean,
you look at the sign. I always tell everyone, look at the sign at the beach.
Uh, in the fifties, they didn't have a sign. At some point it was like,
no bonfires between 3:00 AM and 6:00 AM. You know what I mean?
Now? It's like, no Frisbee, no dogs, no football,
no cigarettes, no, no humans, no humans. Like literally.
Yeah, no humans on the beach. And when, think about what,
think about how they ratchet it up. Think about how the sign gets longer.
They always add something to the sign.
They never remove something from the beach sign every year.
There's two more things you can't do on the beach.
And when you go physically look at the signs,
now it is a scroll of things.
Citizens can't do on our beach.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.